welcome to the kill test
it will kill
[Music]
the war galac
originating in the philippines during
the 16th century the war galact featured
a straight double-edged blade with no
tip due to the spanish occupation at the
time filipinos were outlawed from having
pointed swords and the blade was often
used for vegetation and chopping wood
however by the philippine revolution in
1896 filipinos adapted to the tipless
weapon and it became a weapon of war it
was so effective in battle and inspired
later variations of the weapons such as
the british military's army galac in the
early 1950s
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
five days
my name is matt wagner i run an auto
body restoration shop and i work with
metal every day i started watching
forged and fire and then one day i was
like you know what i think i can do that
i'm ready to crank this baby up
i'm anxious because i have never made a
sword this long
i want to win this competition because
i've always thought i was meant to do
something better my main concern is
quenching the blade because it could
create massive warping
this is the big moment
it's freaking straight
so now that i'm quenched i'd like to
take a couple whacks at a piece of wood
just to see what's gonna happen
[Music]
i've shattered my blade into three
pieces
this is an epic failure
i'm running out of time
i'm gonna have to start over
i might not finish this thing my plan is
to use a piece of leaf spring and get a
complete sword forged out in one day
i'm working on a deadly timeline and i
am just busting my
i gotta get my clench done by the end of
day four because
i don't know if i have a good blade yet
i may have to build another one tomorrow
you never know it's cool pretty quick
i'm running out of time
if this blade doesn't harden with this
quench i'm really screwed i got my
fingers crossed
we've got a hard blade
i am super happy
looks like i'm gonna have something for
the big show
[Music]
my name is brian schmidt
i believe my great-grandfather was a
blacksmith so when i saw forge and fire
i wanted to try and make my own blades
and just create memories with my family
i think i have a pretty good chance of
winning the basic shape of my blade is
in there now this is going to be the
oregonic the blade's looking really nice
got the handle set up for a lot of work
today
the handle's made out of maple it's also
the part of the knife where i'm
customizing it for myself a little bit
yeah not so bad i think they turned out
pretty nice i sharpened my blade three
times
the things razor sharp all right
feels good
now i want to go test the blade and my
son is joining me
ready all right here we go
oh
awesome
that thing slices right through it feels
good in my hand so i think it's gonna do
well all right very deadly bladesmiths
to see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do we'll take your sword and
deliver hacks and slashes on this big
carcass
brian you're up first you ready for this
absolutely depending on where you hit
that blade you know it can always snap
apart
bladesmiths but unfortunately i'm still
recovering from an injury so
anthony one of my senior instructors of
mark ida kali will be the butcher to
your pork chop
all right brian let's talk about your
blade first up your edge is razor sharp
it lacerated easily through bones to the
spine
the one issue here is that you have a
very blocky handle aside from that it
will kill good job thanks
matt ready to chop i've been ready let's
do this
i am really nervous
but as long as this blade doesn't wrap
around in a circle and hug this pig i'm
in good shape
[Music]
okay matt it's balancing weight is very
forward for a chopper but your edge is
sharp enough to lacerate into the
carcass it did chop the spine it did
chop bone
this
will kill
thank you
gentlemen
this is a strength test to test the
strength and durability of your edge i'm
going to chop into these huge logs 10
times remember this test is all about
what happens to your weapons and not
what happens to the logs brian you're up
first you ready i think so yeah all
right
[Music]
[Music]
made it
well brian
your edge held up perfectly
there's no bending no warping just still
razor sharp all the way down
man
it was fun to swing well done thank you
matt you're up you ready give it a try
all right
[Music]
ah
well matt there's so much forward weight
that it actually
bent that way on the plus side
your edge helps beautifully i mean
there's no problems with that edge at
all it's still very sharp
but this s-bend in it
it's significant
bladesmiths you both brought in some
pretty extraordinary historic weapons
but in this arena of competition there
can only be one forged and fire champion
[Music]
brian
congratulations you are the new forged
and fire champion
matt unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut
matt your blade is impressive we saw
that it could kill but unfortunately in
the strength test it took a significant
bend and it's for that reason we have to
let you go
i understand
matt please surrender your glock
even with losing at the end of the day i
don't feel like i really lost because i
went way further than i ever expected i
don't know enough about it yet that i
can make that perfect blade so
you know i'll keep learning
brian you are the new forged and fire
champion and that comes with a check for
ten thousand dollars good job thank you
guys thank you
please present your weapon to the judges
it feels great to be forged the fire
champ i can't believe i won it's awesome
i would say if somebody wants to start
learning how to make a knife start out
watching fortune fire you started
episode one binge watch
[Music]
[Music]
the zonde spear
oh boy one of the deadliest weapons used
by the zombae tribes of central africa
the zonde spear was used for fighting as
well as for hunting known throughout
history as conquering warriors the zonde
exhibited unmatched skills on the
battlefield affixed to a wooden shaft
the spear was suitable for throwing and
attacking from long distances but his
thrusting ability made it just as
effective as a close combat weapon
the sharp upper and lower tines and
multiple spikes inflicted deadly wounds
both upon entry and exit from the
victim's body the zonde's lethal use of
the spear can be seen highlighted in the
game deadliest warrior
good luck we'll see you in five days
my name is drew goodson i'm 18 years old
i started bladesmithing seriously
because of this show and i study
mechanical engineering at louisiana tech
i've noticed that doug liked recurved
blades i don't know if that's how he
likes his women curvy but my grandmother
has totally got a crush on him
especially when he says it will kill
i've taken that
20 inch piece of steel and just by doing
that much
drawn it to
over 21 inches
i want to get the spearhead completely
forged today i'm going to forge weld two
pieces of steel on either end of this
because it's getting thin and i don't
want this to bend in a slightest i know
in the testing they're going to abuse my
weapon but i'm not worried about it
because i know what i'm doing
dig myself in the head wow
three
two
one
i'm sitting here waiting for a ping or a
pop or
something scraping but i don't hear it
just a nice little sizzle
oh god
i just lost part of my time
this
little freaking thin one it broke off
i'm freaking out right now that's really
not good
i don't have enough steel to make
another time
i have to start over making another
blade
i've got three hours to get this done
and
i've just got to get at it once i've
done this i'm gonna cut in stick it in
the forge and spread those out
good plan good plan
and i've allowed the entire day to
finishing the shack of this beer fitting
sharpening nothing big the tank doesn't
quite fit in the shaft
why why is this happening i'm almost
over the height requirement
uh okay
crisis averted i'm all good i don't even
know what i feel right now
okay
that's a panic good kid oh yep
yep
can chill out
okay bladesmiths i will take your zombie
spear and deliver killing blows on this
ballistic stummy
drew you're up first you ready
let's make those intestines out testings
all right let's do that i like that
[Music]
right now
i'm about to hear doug say it will kill
and that's the only thing i'm here for
to help me out today please welcome back
rj marcaida he will have the pleasure of
wielding your zombie spear
[Music]
right drew it feels very good in the
hand it lacerates deep when we thrust
this into the chest cavity into the
heart on its way out not only does it
take some skin with it but it also took
out some ribs
your tines right here from the side
entry the spear went all the way through
and on its way out it took everything
that was in its path but there is one
issue as you can see
your tip right here broke off
but other than that this is a weapon
that is deadly and it will kill
thank you
all right jason your turn you ready i
know it'll cut
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right jason the balance of your
weapon feels good when it penetrated
into the chest cavity it hit a rib and
broke it in half got into the heart and
there was no edge damage on your tip
all these hooks right here did what it's
supposed to do into the abdomen ripped
everything out even the barb and the
beautiful thing about this is it will
kill
that's what i wanted to hear
say hello to my little friend here
today we're going to test the overall
strength and construction of your zande
spears by well we're going to fire him
out of this cannon into this wood block
wall
now i'm not concerned about what your
spears do to the wall i want to see how
well your spears survived the wall
drew you're up first are you ready no
well we're gonna do it anyway
that worked really well drew
despite the fact that you did lose a
little bit of your tip in the kill test
didn't have any effect going into that
block wall matter of fact you sunk
all the way down here very impressive
your shaft is fine nothing loosened up
nothing cracked your spear head is still
solid
overall
survived very good thank you
so jason what are you thinking thinking
let's make splinters
that's a problem
oh god no
i'm seeing it hang up a bit on the
barrel and my heart just absolutely
sinks
jason we've got a big problem here the
parameters that we set for these weapons
are for testing purposes because your
blade didn't meet the inch and a half
parameter with a circular cross section
we cannot fit the shaft of your weapon
down the barrel of our testing apparatus
here and because we can't test it evenly
and fairly with drew's blade i have to
ask you to please leave the forge
this was absolutely
worst case scenario i'm proud that i got
this far but i'm incredibly disappointed
well drew in a competition where
attention to detail is just as critical
as craftsmanship you are the force and
fire champion and will be collecting a
check for ten thousand dollars good
job oh my god
oh
how do you feel right now
i'm 18 year old
and i'm the fortune fire champion what
what just happened well i think the best
blade just won my friend come over here
and shake our hands oh my god
didn't want to win this way but i won
and that's kind of all that matters
i started bladesmithing seriously
because of the show
i learned
all that i had to learn to make it here
and i just won
this this is the dream
oh my god man
the mesopotamian sickle sword
the sickle sword originated in
mesopotamia at the height of the bronze
age around 2500 bc
these sickle and curved shaped swords
often symbolized royalty and power and
were primarily wielded during ceremonies
by kings and authority figures
although these swords were not common on
the battlefield the belly of the blade
allowed for quick devastating blows and
inspired designs for later weapons such
as the deadly egyptian kopech good luck
we will see you in four days
my name is robert taylor i'm from
brentwood california i'm a sergeant with
the san francisco sheriff's department i
took up bladesmithing because i'd like
to watch fortune fire
it's something i really want to go
further in i'm an abs smith maybe a
master smith someday because i love
fortune so i'm going to go 500 layers of
damascus on each side with a 1084 center
core all right we're going for our final
forge weld long as i'm solid with my
steel 1084 will give it more stronger
center the the place where i want the
bend will bend down and then the tip
will start bending up automatically as i
hit it i'm whacking it on the horn to
get it to bend down it's easier than
using the hammer
i like it got the build all ready for
the quench this crunch doesn't go right
i'm going to have to go ahead and start
over and that's going to suck
went in pretty hot
we'll see if we have any bad forge welds
we have a hard blade i want to keep it
light enough and balance enough for
somebody to swing it
getting there i feel really good about
my weapon
getting all the fit up done i think this
thing's gonna slice anything they put
before it
placements welcome to the kill test
so to find out what kind of lethal
damage they will do i'm gonna take your
weapons deliver some lethal blows of
this ballistics
dummy jacob be up first ready cut the
head off let's do that
[Applause]
all right jacob let's talk about your
sickle sword right here your edge is
razor sharp coupled with the fact that
this is a very light weapon i can use
velocity to really wield that sharp edge
it cuts deep into this ballistics dummy
and overall sir your weapon
you'll kill thank you
all right robert your turns are you
ready i'm ready let's do this
all right robert let's talk about your
sickle sword it's a very light blade
that much lighter than the other one and
the angle that you have in here lends
itself to use not only velocity but the
sharpness of your edge to cut very deep
into this ballistics dummy and overall
sir
you will kill thank you
[Music]
bladesmiths welcome to the strength test
the armored warrior chop
test the strength and overall durability
of your mesopotamian sickle swords i'm
going to be chopping into these armored
warriors jacob you're up first you're
ready for this i don't think i get a
choice you don't have a choice
come on
what actually happened is your sword bit
into the other sword by about 3 16 of an
inch and it took out this chip and once
that chip was gone the whole sword blew
up
your grain looks good
but unfortunately uh it's just
this sword against that sword this time
that's road one yep
all right jacob we hate to see this
happen you gave us a beautiful blade but
unfortunately it did suffer a
catastrophic failure on the seventh
strike but you're not out of the fight
yet
because robert in order to become the
champion you will have to survive
every single one of those seven strikes
on the armored warrior are you ready
let's roll the dice all right ben
good job
well robert the big thing is it's one
sword nice job thank you
well robert you made it through all the
testing jacob it's a beautiful piece of
work unfortunately due to your
catastrophic failure we cannot continue
testing it for that reason i'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off the
forge floor thank you gentlemen it was
an honor thank you very much
very nice job thank you
uh
you know it it totally sucks
but i really am proud of the blade i
made either way you know they said
pretty much nothing but good things
about it up until it broke and well i'd
totally come back for this and maybe get
a shot at making it all the way through
robert we never like to see competitors
blades break but yours did not and that
makes you the newest fortune fire
champion you just got yourself a check
for 10 000 congratulations thanks
thanks feel pretty good crazy dude crazy
winning this championship i think has
really pushed me to my limits and then
that makes me want to push them even
more now i'm a champion i'm going to go
ahead and get my abs smith membership
and just really refine my skills
the serrated indian saber
the serrated indian saber traces its
origins back to 18th century india the
deadly weapon features a long curved
blade with serrated edges designed to
intimidate enemies and penetrate deep
into the thick leather armor worn by
infantry and cavalry forces of the time
this blade played an important role as
the sword used by indian forces during
the bloody 1857 uprising against british
rule known as the sapoi mutiny
without further ado guys good luck we
will see you in four days
go kill it brother
[Music]
my name is mark smith i'm from china
spring texas i'm a design engineer for a
local bank equipment manufacturer
season three of fortune fire i started
watching it
about that time i weighed close to 400
pounds
fortune fire was a driver to get more
healthy i lost about 150 pounds from
blade smithing and
life is good
it's taking more time than i anticipated
to get the material down to the thinness
that i want
and then we'll be ready to go and start
doing the features of the saber
fitting the guard i have to be careful
if i remove too much material off the
inside of the guard there's going to be
big gaps it's not going to fit tight
and if it doesn't i'm probably going to
redo the guard
it should be fine it should be okay
so i'm quenching the blade today
i don't think i get it any straighter
than that
there's no cracks and everything's
looking pretty good right now i dyed the
epoxy gold because it looks cool and
it's close to
the bronze guard i think it has a nice
touch to it
winning this competition would be like
winning the super bowl
it's about showing that
foraging fire has turned my life around
and given me the skills
to do this
basements welcome to the dynamic heel
test
mark your first you ready for this
blade's ready
so
all right mark to talk about your weapon
here your handle is a little bit on the
rounded side but the saving grace is
this flare that you have there it
allowed me to get my hand in here and
it's locked in between your guard
and your pommel good on that
now you did pick up
one
small chip where it cut the bone
but other than that
it'll kill thank you
i know your turn are you ready i'm ready
[Music]
all right ira first up the slices into
this ballistics dummy thrusting and
using the teeth i can really feel
everything on the blade but what's more
important is the wheel the ability of
this weapon it's so nice and light and i
can control every move
overall sir your indian serrated saber
you will kill
all right gentlemen welcome to our
dynamic strength test sticking with our
sheet metal theme our sheet metal chop
and bag slice
so mark you're up first you ready she's
got this but i might need a hug
all right mark right off your blade is
still
in the shape it came in felt good
cutting it's a little on the forward
heavy side i would have seen that
balance just a little bit further back
but it didn't affect the cuts at all so
good job
ready to play ira
not really
[Laughter]
i am
[Music]
[Music]
so ira
first off
the shape and scale of this is really
beautiful the way it just flows from one
point to the other the taper really
really nice he took one chip in the
blade right here
but other than that this is still i'm
not gonna run my finger down this blade
it's still short well done
thank you
well gentlemen in the first two rounds
of this competition you both proved your
worth by making knives out of sheet
metal and in this final round you both
knocked it out of the park with the most
intricate blades i've seen in a long
time but in this competition only one of
you can take home the title and a check
for ten thousand dollars
our judges did agree
that today's fortune fire champion is
ira congratulations i'm mark
unfortunately at this point i'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off the
fourth floor been a tremendous pleasure
thank you job mark
i'm happy that it came down to such
details i think any other competition i
could have gone on the winner
well ira congratulations sir you are the
newest fortune fire champion and you
just received a check for ten thousand
dollars congratulations
just one forging fire it feels pretty
awesome that's a beautiful example of
that weapon i think you nailed it well
thank you the whole experience has been
super fun
for the stressful part of building the
first knife playing with the coal iron
press i think that's where the money's
going
sergeant hayden sword
[Music]
sergeant william hayden one of the first
english colonists in 17th century
connecticut is best known for his heroic
actions during the pequod war of 1637
after rising tensions between the
colonists and the pequod tribe erupted
payton and a group of english settlers
were sent to capture territory in modern
day mystic connecticut
during the battle with a sharp swipe of
his single-edged slightly curved blade
hayden famously cut the string of a
pequod warrior's bow that was taking
direct aim at the english captain john
mason saving his life
the original historic sword is still on
display today in connecticut's
historical society museum in hartford
connecticut
so good luck we will see you in four
days
good luck
my name is stephanie ayudo i'm 31 years
old i live in new york city and i'm a
part-time bladesmith
i've always had an appreciation for
knives and armor so i googled you know
new york city fleet smith and i found
fionez who was a former contestant on
fortune fire he won his round back in
season three and then his champions
round
and yeah now we're just forging buddies
and i'm happy to keep making new knives
my blade's the right length curve is the
right depth i'm feeling good and i'm
ready to quench
this is the moment of truth
just like less
successful quench i am feeling good i am
feeling tired but good i've got my mild
steel bar in the forage bringing up to
temp once it's at the right temperature
i'm gonna be pressing it down trying to
turn a long tube into a short pancake
i'm a little behind where i'd like to be
barely made it done spent a couple of
hours working on my guard but it isn't
doing what i wanted to do i've gotta
scrap this and start fresh
i gotta change now or the whole day's
gonna be sunk
that might work
okay
it's the end of the day looking at my
guard it's a little fugly at the moment
but there's nothing tlc can't fix let's
do it slow and steady
don't want to break anything all right
hello boys i am ready to show my friends
theo and justin to former forge and fire
contestants
well that's looking deadly very proud of
you that looks great thank you thank you
i'm just excited to see the judges use
it
placements welcome to the keel test
to find out how lethal your weapons are
i'm gonna take your weapons deliver some
lethal blows on this ballistics dummy
stephanie you're up first you ready for
this go have your fun
so
all right stephanie let's talk about
your sword here your edge is
sharp
i mean that's one of the cleanest
decapitations i've done with a sword
overall
your weapon
it will kill thank you
right nathan are you ready it's your
turn sir you bet
[Music]
all right nathan let's talk about your
sword here
those are very deep cuts every swing
penetrated deep every thrust went all
the way through
your weapons sir
it will kill thank you
[Music]
all right bladesmiths you know what time
it is it's time for the strength test
to test the strength and durability of
your blades i'll be attacking our wooden
palisades here stephanie you're up first
you ready oh yeah all right
all right so stephanie in the test your
blade held up really well there's a one
small chip it took and then maybe a
little bit of a glinting spot here but
it's still sharp we get back to here
your tang
kind of kicks this way and then sort of
curves back this way what that does is
every time i hit it kind of rides
forward into that guard didn't really
hurt my knuckle but over time it's going
to be an issue but everything's tight it
held up really well in this test good
job thank you
all right nathan you're up you ready you
bet
[Music]
so nathan really nicely done i ran my
fingernail down that blade and i cannot
feel any deformation
any next nothing so it's pristine your
handle shape
comfortable it's got that nice flare to
it
the guard's out of my way so i'm not
hitting it nicely done good sword thank
you
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpest test the fish slice
now a sharp edge should be able to cut
all the way through this fish and that's
what i'd like to see it's definitely
your first you ready for this go do your
thing
[Music]
all right stephanie let's talk about
your weapon here when cutting through
the salmon
no issues at all it cut all the way
through now when you got to the grouper
which is a scalier and thicker fish you
went more than half overall it will cut
thank you
all right nathan your turns are you
ready you bet
all right nathan let's talk about your
weapon here your edge when cutting
through the salmon no resistance easy
cuts on the grouper you cut in more than
half overall your weapon you will cut
thank you
well blaise miss in this third round we
ask you to go back to your home fortunes
for four days and come back with strong
sharp sergeant hayden soares and you
both did it now in this competition only
one of you can go home the champion and
our judges have talked it through and
they've made a decision today's fortune
fire champion is
nathan congratulations man now stephanie
unfortunately your blade did not make
the cut i'm gonna have to ask you to
please step off the forge floor
this has been a crazy journey
i'm very proud of my work but coming so
close that you can almost taste it i
definitely want to come back and give it
one more go to see if i can be the
fortune fire champion
well nathan you know what that means man
you are the forge of fire champion and
you just got yourself a check for ten
thousand dollars congratulations i
cannot believe i won i know it happened
it doesn't quite seem real
how do you feel
i have no idea
making this weapon i put everything i
had into it trying to make something
nice and i'm overwhelmed i cannot
believe i won i'm nathan butcher i'm the
forged and fire champion
you